Caption: and here is Don thanks mate cheers
Caption: all right I'm just conscious uh we're at
Caption: the end of the day it's the afternoon so
Caption: we're going to try and
Caption: uh do a very quick fire my presentation
Caption: today is a very lightweight type
Caption: presentation it's nice it's it's a brain
Caption: candy but it does have an important
Caption: message in it and that important message
Caption: is about test Automation and one of the
Caption: biggest blockers that most teams out
Caption: there get wrong and it's what's stopping
Caption: your automation from being successful
Caption: now I'm going to tell this story today
Caption: about a naked Emperor is there a naked
Caption: emperor in your development team it's a
Caption: story that's a thousand years old it's
Caption: been done in 100 different languages
Caption: today you're going to get a very short
Caption: very Aussie sort of version of that is
Caption: how I like things and we'll fire through
Caption: that and as I'm doing that put your
Caption: thinking caps on and just think how what
Caption: is this guy talking about how the hell
Caption: is this relating to test automation see
Caption: if you can piece it together because
Caption: I'll give you the answer at the end
Caption: right so before I kick off I really want
Caption: to thank the sponsors of the day it's
Caption: such a good day connecting with people
Caption: with so many familiar faces in the
Caption: audience I hope you've all you're all
Caption: enjoying DDD make sure you thank the
Caption: organizers they volunteer and they spend
Caption: a lot of time putting this thing
Caption: together each year and I'm proud to
Caption: represent Planet if you haven't seen us
Caption: on the coffee cart we're just around in
Caption: the center of the auditorium and it's um
Caption: I'd love to offer you a t-shirt but they
Caption: went in like an hour hundreds and
Caption: hundreds of t-shirts but we can offer
Caption: you a coffee
Caption: right
Caption: into the stories the stories about an
Caption: emperor so this Emperor is a vain bloke
Caption: he's very fixated on his looks he thinks
Caption: he's a good looking rooster but he
Caption: always wants to look better than
Caption: everyone else
Caption: out in his Empire he's got these two
Caption: great creators or we'll call them
Caption: developers to give you a clue and these
Caption: guys are really good at making things in
Caption: fact they're so good at making things
Caption: back in those days they thought they
Caption: were magicians the emperor gets word of
Caption: these guys and he says look
Caption: brings them into his uh into his throne
Caption: room and he says
Caption: I want you to make me the most
Caption: magnificent outfit ever made
Caption: whatever I want to do wherever I want to
Caption: be
Caption: it needs to be a magical outfit that
Caption: makes me look magnificent 24 hours a day
Caption: and these guys are like
Caption: they get they get locked away in a room
Caption: and they're thinking uh okay that's an
Caption: interesting challenge we've got here
Caption: so they set about doing what they know
Caption: they build things they set up Machinery
Caption: they shut up equipment and they've got
Caption: this continuous delivery fashion line
Caption: which they're sort of creating one small
Caption: problem though
Caption: as they're locked away in this little
Caption: dungeon area
Caption: we don't have any fabric to work with
Caption: what we went to do and the emperor says
Caption: book you guys are so talented you're so
Caption: good at making things you're practically
Caption: magicians I'm sure you'll work it out
Caption: um and they're a bit puzzled they're
Caption: stressing right because these guys are
Caption: going to get their heads locked off by
Caption: this bloke when they shot with nothing
Caption: but they know he's uh he's equally Vain
Caption: and equally stupid so they come up with
Caption: an idea because these are the Smart Guys
Caption: in the story
Caption: two days pass the emperor brings them in
Caption: and says right I've given you this
Caption: challenge show me what you've made for
Caption: me show me This Magnificent outfit
Caption: they're all in a rack full of coat
Caption: hangers with absolutely nothing on it
Caption: and they tell him don't worry about it
Caption: we've built you this amazing outfit
Caption: that's so spectacular it's actually
Caption: magical only people that are loyal to
Caption: the Empire can see the clothes right
Caption: it's sort of magical clothes
Caption: and uh
Caption: the emperor is like
Caption: okay yeah I can see them now yeah they
Caption: look spectacular right because he
Caption: doesn't want to be disloyal to his own
Caption: an Empire
Caption: the guys aren't stupid though I think
Caption: right the moment the emperor goes out of
Caption: here someone's going to tell him he's
Caption: wearing nothing if he puts these things
Caption: on which is nothing and we're going to
Caption: be in a lot of trouble so they tell him
Caption: why don't you go out in the town
Caption: tomorrow
Caption: do a parade down the Main Street and
Caption: anyone that says anything
Caption: lock the heads off because they're not
Caption: loyal to the Empire
Caption: Emperor is right cool I got this next
Caption: day puts on the gear
Caption: goes out down the Main Street thinking
Caption: he's looking pretty good
Caption: um he's all smiles and Giggles there's a
Caption: few people in the in the crowd as you
Caption: can imagine sort of a bit of murmuring
Caption: like what is this guy what's his idiot
Caption: doing he's wearing no clothes you and I
Caption: know he's completely starkers right he's
Caption: wearing these
Caption: magnificent clothes of absolutely
Caption: nothing
Caption: um
Caption: no one says anything though because no
Caption: one wants to get the headlocked off
Caption: except for one guy this guy and in the
Caption: story this guy is me and the reason is
Caption: this is the guy that doesn't care about
Caption: all that stuff he just calls out what he
Caption: sees and he's going to tell it like it
Caption: is
Caption: and he says hang on what's the emperor
Caption: doing with no clothes
Caption: come on mate no one wants to see that
Caption: get some bloody clothes on
Caption: and at that moment
Caption: the emperor realizes he's been made to
Caption: look like a complete fool these guys
Caption: have really set him up for failure and
Caption: it and it's actually bloody embarrassing
Caption: because he has nothing on
Caption: cool story what the hell's this got to
Caption: do with this automation I don't worry I
Caption: can see your faces there's sort of like
Caption: lots of forward brows out there we'll
Caption: get to it so what's it got to do with
Caption: test automation well similar if I look
Caption: around the room here we've got lots of
Caption: great developers right in the community
Caption: we're really good at making things
Caption: creating things
Caption: but we're not magicians but occasionally
Caption: you get an emperor who will say look
Caption: with test automation can you guys just
Caption: go set that thing up I wanna I want some
Caption: Auto magical automated tests please I
Caption: want them to run 24 hours a day cicd
Caption: cxcz whatever they could ask for
Caption: anything and by the way it should make
Caption: my coffee as well so they expect the
Caption: impossible from the Developers
Caption: developers will do what they do they'll
Caption: go and get the latest Frameworks and
Caption: toolkits they'll set it all up they'll
Caption: build the pipe you've got the nice
Caption: pipeline running
Caption: beautiful
Caption: one problem
Caption: if you don't have fabric
Caption: what are you making you're making
Caption: nothing similar to the story without the
Caption: fabric you've got a lot of Machinery a
Caption: lot of time and expense put in and
Caption: you're making nothing
Caption: so what's the fabric when you're
Caption: building test automation what is that
Caption: what's in the word test right it's in
Caption: the name
Caption: without a good test you've got nothing
Caption: so if you think about fabric good thread
Caption: count right color right texture durable
Caption: wearable good good quality
Caption: characteristics it's the same as your
Caption: tests
Caption: good tests
Caption: are carefully crafted and targeted they
Caption: take a lot of thought to get the right
Caption: tests and they typically come from the
Caption: mind of a tester
Caption: need to be really well made great fabric
Caption: great garments great tests great test
Caption: automation but how do you get the fabric
Caption: well fabric makers make fabric
Caption: and testers make tests
Caption: okay
Caption: testers are our special special breed
Caption: these days we are told
Caption: oh but we're all cross-functional we're
Caption: all unicorns right so we can all we're
Caption: all full stack devs we all code like
Caption: demons
Caption: um I could run the agile rituals better
Caption: than that seasoned scrum master and I
Caption: know more about product ownership than
Caption: the product owner and of course we're
Caption: all legendary testers right
Caption: uh no not so much that's not reality
Caption: that's the textbook the reality is
Caption: we all specialize those those different
Caption: roles are fundamentally different in
Caption: terms of how you think in terms of your
Caption: career progression the study and the
Caption: time you've put into them
Caption: so
Caption: I'll put it to you another way every
Caption: tester out there has dabbled a little
Caption: bit in coding and there's a very small
Caption: number of testers who are so good at
Caption: coding I'd say they're probably as good
Caption: as developers but I wouldn't then go out
Caption: and say hey testers you've all dabbled
Caption: in coding you're all now developers go
Caption: start writing our Enterprise systems you
Caption: wouldn't do that that would be
Caption: ridiculous
Caption: so
Caption: the reverse is also true when the
Caption: emperor has asked developers and they
Caption: say look you guys are amazing at coding
Caption: you should all be involved in testing
Caption: all good developers are but we don't
Caption: expect you to be professional testers
Caption: because that's a different career path
Caption: it's different skills and it's different
Caption: it's a whole different background to
Caption: life so
Caption: professional testers if you've ever
Caption: worked with one they're a different read
Caption: they think differently
Caption: they are magnets for errors a normal
Caption: person
Caption: choose my words I'm a test ironic so
Caption: I'll go with that they might think of
Caption: five five things that could go wrong a
Caption: tester will tell you 101 things that
Caption: will go wrong they're fixated on
Caption: breaking things not making things it's a
Caption: completely different mindset in an
Caption: interview I can tell you within two or
Caption: three questions whether someone's a
Caption: developer or a tester by how they answer
Caption: those questions whatever they think they
Caption: might be it's quite evident brains work
Caption: differently they've also spent years
Caption: training in their profession learning
Caption: skills techniques getting certifications
Caption: in testing specifically for testing to
Caption: create that great Fabric or tests
Caption: it's a point that Emperors often miss
Caption: now remember the guy in the story
Caption: well in the world of test automation
Caption: that's me I'm not a developer but I do
Caption: get the privilege of working with the
Caption: development teams right across Perth and
Caption: they open their doors and we see the
Caption: automation that's being produced
Caption: and while some shops are doing an
Caption: incredible job they're creating great
Caption: Automation and it's a beautiful thing
Caption: when you see it
Caption: I'd say the majority or many of them
Caption: have Emperors in the establishment who
Caption: are spending a lot of money and expense
Caption: putting together toolkits spending a lot
Caption: of time building stuff that amounts to a
Caption: whole lot of nothing if I'm being framed
Caption: because I don't have the fabric
Caption: so what are the two lessons two
Caption: takeaways from today how to spot a naked
Caption: Emperor and how to avoid being one
Caption: yourself like don't be that guy that
Caption: asks people to do the impossible
Caption: well firstly
Caption: professional testers make the great
Caption: tests and that's where you get your
Caption: great test automation it's a key
Caption: ingredient that's often missing and
Caption: that's the point of the talk so if you
Caption: want to spot a naked Emperor it's
Caption: someone that's asking developers to do
Caption: things with no fabric
Caption: the second thing is if you're working in
Caption: an environment where you're not getting
Caption: that great fabric
Caption: don't be afraid to be that guy that just
Caption: calls it out because without that people
Caption: are going to continue murmuring in the
Caption: crowd and nodding and pretending like
Caption: yeah we're doing great with automation
Caption: we've got 5 000 tests done and there's a
Caption: whole lot of nothing what that does it
Caption: leaves you exposed and that is bloody
Caption: embarrassing so
Caption: if you're looking to make software
Caption: better
Caption: two two tips from today I hope you
Caption: remember them and I'm happy to have
Caption: discussions afterwards but um hopefully
Caption: that's been lightweight and entertaining
Caption: as I promised thank you very much
Caption: come on
Caption: thank you thank you Don thank you
Caption: Brendan that is the last of our talks
Caption: yeah what a good one to finish on